this is jose hernandez harmace's house
in the distance
just below the gushing crater still
standing
but for how long
he says there was no warning from
authorities but he knew when the earth
under his feet suddenly started shaking
the old summit known as
vieja had once again awoken
i angry i'm so disappointed so many
people have lost their homes we have
nothing left nothing jose and his
neighbors are staying in a nearby
parking lot relying not on the state but
friends and family for help they're in
shock with only a few belongings in a
plastic bag they watch european tourists
flock towards the volcano encouraged by
spain's tourism minister who's described
the eruption as a great show there's um
an incredible natural spectacular and
phenomenal there are not really much
places in the world where you have an
active volcano where you can see that
people go to iceland to to hawaii to
to some places in asia but having beds
here on canary islands is
something very unique
especially the people from the islands
spain's opposition leader denounced what
many on the island describe as disaster
tourism thousands of people have been
displaced in hundreds of home destroyed
this is as close as we can get from the
crater and what you're hearing right now
is liquid rock being shut up into the
air as well as chemicals being released
from the central crater and look right
below us look at the
thick layer of ash just on the asphalt
it's not just on the ground it's also
in a cloud right above us
particles of sulfur dioxide hang in the
air
residents in its path are given less
than an hour to evacuate
i'm trying to get as much as i can off
my house because it's unclear when i
will be able to come back we are still
missing two cats and we want to pick up
some documents photos and some clothes
the government has promised to rebuild
lost houses and say help from the eu is
coming
the eruption on this isolated island has
revealed a fault line between europeans
who see an attraction
and those facing an unfolding tragedy
nicholas hawk al jazeera la palma
canaries